welcome to this video playing
international check car off Sheriff it's
no name maybe that is a guy called
checker off I don't know um with a flag
from Argentina though and it's a Ben Oni
modern benoni oh the snake been on him
oh yeah mmm I forgot how this is played
there are various good lines with this
one with g3 yard so d6 Bishop 850 and g3
I don't know this is the problem with
those lines the snake benoni is not
completely terrible it is risky and
probably not advisable to play against
preparation but well how often do you
play against this is white basically
never so it's often a problem if you
then surprisingly phase it that you have
forgotten how the exact line goes queen
d 3 mm or what yeah maybe this is of
course a bit risky what is doing losing
time but maybe you know okay let's let's
attack it I'm not sure maybe yeah
briefly thought maybe at five but f5s
sir looks really crazy okay what about
hmm my almost feel tempted to play stuff
like 95 here it's got very little
defense on the kingside than age for ya
hmm yeah come on feel adventurous here
if I go now h4 let's see h4 h5 just
playing just playing simple chest 95
maybe okay so i probably should prevent
that jump yeah I guess this age for my
business it is a bit riskier and not
necessary but okay I thought isn't and
this runs into 94 I didn't really think
this is good but maybe it it's okay yeah
okay I'll f5 so 190 MLK I guess I need
to do this anyway it detects e5
I'm done I still have a v8 wife coming
yeah yeah it feels dangerous for black
hair mean I just threatened to take and
and and it's it's basically gone 95 yeah
and turned the check here Wow yeah let's
just just do here 25 is an enormous
threat the H file is opening it what
really always give is just giving up the
exchange on and I have a hard time to
understand that okay I'm giving the
check first oh wait I cannot so give the
check on c4 this is actually better to
not run into check they discovered a
tech of the night the problem is not
only I mean what does this move now King
h8 takes on 36 and I'm breaking through
on the edge file yeah I can just go look
aged seven now
okay Jack let's just win the Queen and
watch now something to get the rook into
the game probably just the special King
need to Andrew catch one yeah as
mentioned this opening is risky push up
a three on my arm okay this should be
enough
just take it right just exchanged some
pieces takes here rook takes King f1
kingi to where ok check and then look h1
is always playing without day five
bishop that's an additional problem
I'm not so sure this 95 business I think
it was very dangerous at least I mean
maybe he had some some way to defend but
it didn't really it wasn't an obvious
defense I guess
look look takes a take on a phone mmm
for g5 now yeah should be should be okay
I forgot about that move how could I
forget about the small hmm that's not so
easy now okay I'm proved here I thought
you need to go up to 600 this was silly
check okay probably it it's not it's not
so so much of a problem but I made I
made life more difficult than necessary
check in general it's quite useful to
have rooks traded yeah okay it's still
it's still pretty comfortable because
because of the the bishop that's not
playing
check
yeah f5 f5 is coming check
g6 rook takes check and it promotes
right yes check check yeah I'm not sure
for effects on time I'm not sure about
the the real value of 95 it it is
interesting that that's clear meanie
lost enormous amount of time here the
compounds to play Bishop g2 and possible
Bishop d5 yeah that's it's certainly not
a bad idea oh that's an interesting well
that's interesting very very nice
defensive news okay it probably forces a
queen trade that's funny
ya know something like that maybe I
don't know it's at 5 volts so now this
seems too yeah there's a certain deal
playable for like I still would say what
words better some of the queenside
always the Queen side is crowded here
but I've got age 5 and another move
still not sure this this however is
almost almost lost I think yeah the
comscore's getting higher and higher 1.5
now probably it will improve if you let
it if you'll give it some time yeah this
is this is this is just dead lost yeah
check probably if there was in some sort
better than that no yeah okay what would
else do you want i'm basically up
material and i have the check the g35
was a bit stupid i mean i really forgot
about rook air-five I thought you must
play book g6 city check and this um just
took took some time but it's always a
win yeah the whole opening is it's a bit
risky but I don't I cannot really tell
if this is this is a critical line or
not he he should prolly probably should
avoid 94 and play something like castles
or b6 I don't know something normal move
developing or b6 I know not not lose any
more time not sure why why not ephors is
played here it just seems to do some
more time okay thanks for watching